big strong powerful Donald Trump is
chickening out a recognizing the
Armenian Genocide as a genocide right
after a threat from Turkish president
air Dewan the Senate recently passed a
bipartisan measure to recognize the
Armenian Genocide for what it is it was
a genocide and this was passed as a
foreign policy position it was a rare
bipartisan bill the 1915 killings were
1.5 million Armenians were killed by the
Ottoman Empire was a genocide and that's
what the Senate said and that's what
they intended to recognize president
air21 then came in and issued a threat
saying if you do that Turkey will
recognize the killing of Native
Americans in retaliation we'll talk
about that later and Trump has had the
State Department reject the measure from
the Senate saying that no matter what
the Senate says the position of the
United States on this issue is not going
to change saying quote this is
spokesperson Morgan or Tagus in a
statement to the hill the position of
the administration has not changed our
views are reflected in the president's
definitive statement from April now if
you go back to April on April 24 that
was global Armenian Remembrance Day
Trump said that 1.5 million Armenians
were quote deported massacred or marched
to their deaths and when you say that
anyone who understands the nuances of
the Armenian Genocide understands you
are not saying 1.5 million were killed
and therefore you are not recognizing it
as a genocide when you say 1.5 million
were deported massacred or marched to
their deaths
you could be suggesting that of the 1.5
million 1.49 9 million were merely
deported right and that is why anyone
who understands this issue understands
that you've really got to look at the
letter of what is being said here to
understand it now let's be totally
transparent here in thorough it's not
just Trump that won't simply say the
Armenian Genocide was a genocide for
example when Barack Obama was a
candidate back in 2008 he said it was a
genocide
and then when he became president the
administration did not support a
resolution which said that it was a
genocide so this is a far bigger issue
than just Donald Trump of course now as
far as the Turkish threat to recognize
the genocide by European settlers in the
United States against Native Americans
that really shouldn't scare anyone I
mean it is our history it's what
happened many countries have a very ugly
history look it I was born in Argentina
a lot of people say David why are there
no black people in Argentina it's it's
ugly right I mean that that's the
reality and we can't ignore history we
know historically why there are no black
people in Argentina we know what
happened here in the United States the
idea that people might not know that is
disheartening but it unfortunately may
be a reality in some circles and
meanwhile you have Donald Trump calling
Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas regularly we
here in Donald Trump are talking about
the weakest self-professed strong man
that we have maybe ever seen he's a
genius but we can't see his grades and
he'll sue you if you release them he's
super rich but we can't see his taxes
and he will hire lawyer upon lawyer upon
lawyer to make sure that you don't see
his taxes he makes great deals but he
gets bamboozled by North Korea into
thinking that he made a deal when in
fact he got nothing and on and on and on
most of the details you've probably
heard by now but the big picture once
again is that this guy professes to be
one thing and falls embarrassingly short
of that and it's happening once again
here with him being strong on foreign
policy and American sovereignty which
anyone who's been paying attention would
not be surprised by but to some of his
most ardent supporters they see this and
it's the cognitive dissonance of your
dog when they hear your voice come out
of of a speaker they do a little bit of
confusion and disorientation I think is
the way I would describe it let's take a
quick break I do want to talk about this
totally fake staged interview that
Ivanka Trump gave and we've got to talk
about the Afghanistan papers major major
story both of those and your voicemail
coming up after the break